we're now ready to solve
non-homogeneous
second order linear differential
equations with constant coefficients so
what does all that mean well it means a
an equation that looks like this
a times the second derivative
plus b times the first derivative
plus c times the function is equal to
g of x
before i show you an exact an actual
example i want to show you something
interesting that that the general
solution of this non-homogeneous
equation is actually the general
solution of the homogeneous equation
plus a particular solution and i'll
explain what that means in a second so
let's say that h is a solution of the
homogeneous
equation h is
homogeneous and that worked out well
because h for homogeneous
h is solution for homogeneous
solution
for
homogeneous
there should be some shorthand notation
for homogeneous
so what is what what does that mean that
means that
a times the second derivative of h plus
b
times
h
prime plus
c times h is equal to zero that's what i
mean when i say that h is a solution and
actually let's just say that h is the
general solution for the this
homogeneous equation and we know how to
solve that take the characteristic
equation depending on how many roots it
has and whether they're real or complex
you can figure out a general equation a
general solution and then if you have
initial conditions you can substitute
them and get the values of the constants
fair enough now let's say that i were to
say that g
is a solution let's say it's a when i
use g up here let's say what am i well i
don't like using vowels let's say j
let's say j is a particular solution
to this differential equation so what
does that mean that means that
a
times
j prime prime
plus b times
j prime plus c times j
is equal to g
of x
right so
that means or we're just defining j of x
to be
solution
to be a particular solution
particular solution
now what i want to show you is that j
of x plus h of x
is
also going to be a solution to this
original equation and that it's it's the
general solution for this
non-homogeneous equation and and before
i just you know do it mathematically
what's the intuition when you substitute
h here you get 0 when you substitute j
here you get g of x so when you add them
together you're going to get 0 plus g of
x here so you're going to get g of x
here and i'll show you that right now so
let's say
so let's say i wanted to substitute h
plus j here so what is and i'll do it in
a different color
a
so the second derivative of that of that
the sum of those two functions is going
to be the second derivative of both of
them
summed up
plus b times the first derivative of the
sum
plus c times the sum of the functions
and my goal is to show that this is
equal to g of x so what does this
simplify to well if we take all the h
terms we get a
h prime prime plus
b
h prime plus c h
plus let's do all the j terms a
j prime prime
plus b
j prime
plus c
j
well by definition of how we defined h
and j what is this equal to
well we said that h is is a solution for
the homogeneous equation or that this
expression is equal to zero so that
equals zero
and by our definition for j what does
this equal well we said j is a
particular solution for the
non-homogeneous equation or that
this expression is equal to g of x
so this is equal to g of x
so when you
substitute h plus j into this
differential equation on the left hand
side on the right hand side true enough
you get g of x so we've just shown that
if you define h and j this way that the
function i don't know we'll call it
k of x
is equal to h of x
plus j of x i'm running out of space
that is the general solution i haven't
proven that it is the most general
solution but i think you have the
intuition right because the general
solution on the homogeneous one that was
the general solution the most general
solution and now we're adding a
particular solution that gets you the g
of x on the right hand side
that might be very confusing to you so
let's actually try to do it with some
real numbers i think it'll make a lot
more sense
so let's say we have the differential
equations and i'm going to teach you a
technique now for figuring out that g
or that j in the particular in that last
example so how do you figure out that
particular solution
so let's say i have the differential
equation the second derivative of y
minus 3 times the first derivative
minus 4 times y
is equal to
3 e to the 2x
so the first step is we want the hum we
want the general solution of the
homogeneous equation so first we can get
and in that example i just did that
would have been our h of x
so we want the solution of
y prime prime minus 3 y prime minus 4 y
is equal to 0. take the characteristic
equation
s4 is equal to zero
r what is this r minus four
times r plus one is equal to zero
two roots r could be
or
negative 1. and so our general solution
i'll call that h
or let's call that y general
y sub g
so our general solution
is equal to we've done this many times
c1
e to the 4x
plus
c2
e to the minus 1x or minus x
fair enough so
we solved the homogeneous equation so
how do we get a in that last example a j
of x that'll give us a particular
solution so on the right hand side we
get this
well here we just have to think a little
bit and this this method is called the
method of undetermined coefficients and
you have to say well if i want something
some function where i take a second
derivative and add that or subtract it
some multiple of its first derivative
minus some multiple of the function i
get e to the 2x
that function and its derivatives and
the second derivatives must be something
of the form something times e to the 2x
so essentially we take a guess we say
well what
what does it look like
when we take the derivatives and and the
various derivatives and the functions
and we multiply multiples of it plus
each other and all of that then we get e
to the 2x or some multiple of e to the
2x well a good guess could just be
that j which is our well i'll call it y
particular
our particular solution here
could be that and particular solution
i'm using a little different than the
particular solution when we we had
initial conditions here we can view this
as a particular solution a solution that
gives us this on the right hand side so
let's say that the one i pick is some
constant a
times
e to the 2x
if that's my guess then
the derivative of that is equal to 2
a e to the 2x
and the second derivative of that of my
particular solution is equal to 4
a e to the 2x
and now i can substitute in here and
let's see if i can solve for a and then
i'll have my particular solution so the
second derivative that's this so i get 4
a
e to the 2x
minus 3 times the first derivative so
minus 3 times this so that's
minus
a
e to the 2x
minus 4 times the function so minus
a
e to the 2x and all that is going to be
equal to 3 e to the 2x well we know e to
the 2x doesn't equal zero so we can
divide both sides by that just factor it
out really
get rid of all the ease of the 2x and
the left-hand side we have 4a and a
minus 4a well those cancel out
and then lo and behold we have minus six
a
is equal to three divide both sides by
six you get a is equal to minus one half
so there we have our particular solution
it is equal to
minus one half
e to the 2x
and now i like i just showed you before
i cleared the screen
our general solution of this
non-homogeneous equation is going to be
our particular solution plus the general
solution to the homogeneous equation so
our we could call this the most general
solution or i don't know i'll just call
it y
it is our general solution c 1
e to the 4
x plus
whoops
plus
c 2
e to the minus x plus our particular
solution we find found so that's minus
minus one half
e
to the 2x pretty neat
anyway well i'll do a couple more
examples of this i think you'll get the
hang of it in the next example we'll do
something other than a an e to the 2x or
an e function here we'll try to do uh
stuff with polynomials and and trig
functions as well i'll see you in the
next video